[Música]
eu vim do interior de minas uma cidade
bem pequena e quando eu era criança eu
costumava andar pelas ruas da cidade e
olhava os prédios ao meu redor e ficava
imaginando essa provavelmente deve ser a
maior cidade do mundo quando tinha seis
anos de idade
meus pais me deram um atlas uma espécie
de material gráfico que tinha países e
capitais do mundo e lá nesse mapa
quando eu vi uma cidade pela primeira
vez eu percebi que ela era só um ponto
dentro de todo o globo
um pouco depois eu assistir um
documentário na tv ele mostrava um
astronauta lado o espaço vem da terra
eu fiquei pensando provavelmente pra ele
a minha cidade deve ser só uma fagulha
dentro de toda a imensidão do universo
naquele momento eu aprendi que confiar
tem a ver com a forma como olha o mundo
ao meu redor e dependendo de onde
estivesse isso poderia e seria diferente
é um exemplo que vocês vêm de errado
nesse mapa
a gente tá acostumado a ver o mapa um
pouco diferente nesse centro do mundo
está um pouco divertido
será que o nosso centro do mundo está
invertido a gente aprende na escola que
a europa é o centro do mundo
mas se eu lembrasse pra vocês que a
terra uma esfera e no plano cartesiano
centro do mundo então ele pode ser
relativo
esse é um mapa múndi ensinado e muitas
as escolas do japão e como vocês podem
ver o japão é o centro do mundo
esse mapa é tão diferente tão certo como
o nosso a gente tá pra a gente espera
disposto a acreditar que o mundo que a
gente vê hoje é sempre o mais certo mais
verdadeiro
mas a gente é como se tivesse só uma
lente
mas eu aprendi na prática isso é bem
relativo
vou dar um exemplo pessoal pra vocês eu
sou míope tenho mais ou menos seis graus
de miopia não se tivessem lente ou sem
óculos é como se eu chegasse um mundo
completamente diferente
eu vejo pessoas desconhecidas rostos
embaçados o mundo um pouco sem cor
mas quando
bota um óculos com uma lente parece que
o mundo muda
eu vejo todo mundo conhece todo mundo eu
conheço eu começo a ver cores e começa a
haver mais nitidez
isso me faz pensar que no fundo a forma
como eu vejo o mundo muda de acordo com
a lente que eu uso para vê lo
quer um exemplo
o copo está meio cheio meio vazio muitos
de vocês vão ficar discutindo também
cheio está meio vazio
os grandes empreendedores que eu conheci
pouco se importava com essa resposta
enquanto alguns discutiam ele já vem
eles bebiam água do copo e vende esse
copo para outras pessoas continuarem o
debate
no fundo esse é um pensamento que a
gente vê empreendedores da periferia do
rio de janeiro em jovens programadores
de são paulo em jovens que querem mudar
a gestão pública do acre entre tantos
outros que eu tive a oportunidade de
conhecer nesta jornada
e pra eles todos confiar também é ser um
realista otimista
a primeira vez que ouvi esse termo foi
quando eu li um livro do famoso guru de
gestão chamado de collins
nesse livro ele contava a história do
almirante james estoque de meio ambiente
james kok damon é um dos maiores
militares americano com o número de
patentes e ele foi um lutador na guerra
do vietnã
ele teve só nessa aeronave abatida e lá
virou prisioneiro de guerra durante oito
anos
ele ficou em cativeiro ele foi preso
torturado passou frio fome dor
só que um dia ele conseguiu voltar para
casa ele foi resgatado quando ele voltou
pra casa
muitas pessoas começaram a perguntar pra
ele como você fez pra suportar todo esse
tempo em cativeiro e porque outras
pessoas não conseguiam suportar sem como
você
ele falava que os primeiros a morrer no
cativeiro eram os otimistas
os otimistas eles diziam que pensava da
seguinte forma o natal está chegando
quando natal chegar provavelmente será
assunto
o natal chegava os otimistas não eram
soltos
ninguém era solto e otimistas pensava
mas a páscoa chegando na páscoa com
certeza a gente será resgatado a pasta
chegava eles não eram assuntos
vários natais várias pastas e os
otimistas começaram a perder a esperança
eles morriam coração partido já estoque
day ou pensar um pouco diferente
ele falava que você nunca deve confundir
a fé que você irá triunfar no final com
a sua capacidade de encarar a realidade
como ela é no e crua ou e muitas vezes
até muito brutal
esse paradoxo faz a gente entender que a
diferença das pessoas não estão nas
dificuldades que elas enfrentam mas a
capacidade que você tem de lidar com
elas e utilizar seus recursos e de ver o
mundo por isso eu acredito que confiar
também recebi ficar com textos eu vou
dar um exemplo prático pra vocês vão
fazer uma dinâmica rápida
eu vou pedir para vocês agora pensarem
no desenho que representa uma casa
pensaram legal
agora eu quero que vocês pensem num
desenho que represente a palavra
esperança pouquinho mais difícil né
pensaram legal então agora a gente vai
para o gabarito
quando eles pensaram numa casa
provavelmente a pensar em algo parecido
com isso alguns um pouquinho mais
parecido com isso aqui alguns outros
talvez parecido com essa alguns um pouco
mais pensar numa casa um pouquinho maior
mas eu acredito que poucos de vocês
pensarem em algo como isso que também é
uma casa de esperança
será que pensou esperança exatamente
igual ao do colega quando joga no google
a palavra esperança algumas imagens que
aparecem pra gente já mostram que a
palavra têm diferentes significados e
porque casa é tão similar na nossa
cabeça esperança não há gente a pré
disposto a ter algumas coisas na sua
cabeça fixas mas a gente entende muitas
vezes disse algumas palavras elas podem
exceder e soam diferentes dependendo do
contexto que a gente está pensando
dependendo daquilo que está na nossa
mente
onde o ano atrás eu abrir uma
consultoria de inovação e quando fui
pesquisar um pouco mais sobre esse
conceito eu descobri que inovação tá
muito menos vinculada à nossa capacidade
de criar 10 está muito mais a capacidade
de olhar diferente para aquilo que todo
mundo é igual
é um exemplo prático disso vou
apresentar a vocês a história da júlia
a júlia é uma piauiense arretada que
ressignifica ou as oportunidades da
sociedade
ao criar uma loja de roupas de inverno
em teresina
mas por que criar uma loja de roupas de
inverno na uma das capitais mais quentes
do país
ela percebeu foi que na cidade dela
muitas pessoas via quando viajava para
fora do estado viajava para fora do seu
país
elas buscavam comprar coisas em outro
lugar porque não tinham na cidade então
muitas vezes compravam inclusive pela
internet
ela pensou por que não então inverter a
ordem porque não criar uma loja de
roupas de frio aqui na minha cidade e
foi assim que surgiu a oficina de
inverno
por isso com a história da júlia eu
aprendi que no fundo confiar também tem
a ver com construir suas próprias
oportunidades confiar tem a ver com a
arte de você improvisar em arte de rua
como você fazer um limão uma limonada ou
como bom mineiro do limão uma caipirinha
no fundo vários empreendedores que eu
conheci eles tiraram a limitação do sim
eu tivesse se eu tivesse dinheiro
se eu tivesse carro se eu tivesse todos
recursos eu começaria hoje a fazer
alguma coisa para eles o que importa de
verdade é o a não ser que eu faça
a não ser que eu faça algo hoje eu não
conseguiria chegar onde eu quero é um
exemplo prático disso a história do sesi
o cesar é o estudante de biologia que
durante muito tempo acompanha o
tratamento de câncer da sua mãe
durante essa jornada ele teve a idéia de
criar um aplicativo para ajudar outros
pacientes no combate à doença
só que o sesa quando teve essa ideia e
não tinha muitos recursos então decidiu
se inscrever no concurso de startups
ele foi um dos finalistas e como prêmio
ele ganhou um curso de
autorizo nos estados unidos muito legal
essa chance dele pra fazer esse negócio
avançar
só que ele não tinha dinheiro pra isso e
aí ele pensou a não ser que eu faça algo
agora eu perder essa oportunidade
o que ele fez foi começar a pensar qual
os quais os recursos ele tinha
disponível na mão pra começar a chegar
mais longe de juntar esse dinheiro e ele
pensou eu sei fazer brigadeiro
então eu vou começar a vender os
brigadeiros ele fez começou a vender os
colegas para os amigos
ele começou a vender para toda a rede
contato em menos de um mês ele arrecadou
10 mil reais dinheiro que era suficiente
não só para bancar a viagem dele para lá
como também para começar a desenvolver o
negócio dele
se você quer mudar o mundo de verdade
fica parado não é uma alternativa do que
adianta a gente tirar as idéias da
sonhar fora da caixa
se a gente guardar as ações da gaveta
just do it tem uma metáfora que minha
mãe me disse que ela fala o seguinte se
você quer suas oportunidades vai atrás
delas
se você em vez de correr atrás das
oportunidades que não corre na frente
delas
assim se acelera o processo e que uma
discussão acontecerá então é melhor não
contrariar
no fundo essa corrida ela não é uma
corrida de 100 metros é uma maratona
por isso em vez de só mirar na linha
final eu aprendi que confiar também
aproveitar a jornada
um amigo meu uma vez me contou uma certa
história ele voltando de casa de ônibus
ele olhou pela janela do ônibus e na
janela do ônibus ao lado ele viu uma
linda garota
talvez a mulher mais linda que eu já
tenha visto naquele momento na mente
dele ele começou a imaginar
imagina se um dia ele conta essa garota
a gente se conhece a gente começa a
conversar a gente se apaixona
a gente começa a namorar a gente nova a
gente casa ea gente começa a ter uma
vida felizes para sempre juntos
aquilo ficou na cabeça dele gerou uma
felicidade la dessa história no momento
que ele poderia realizar tudo isso ele
continua a acolher e continuou a ida
dele para casa
o ônibus fez uma parada e pela sua
incrível surpresa o ônibus da garota
também fez a parada
ele a viu descendo do ônibus o que ele
fez foi logo se apresentar para ela
eles se conheceram começaram a conversar
e nos primeiros minutos de conversa toda
a mágica desapareceu
ele percebeu que aquela garota tinha
crenças valores e interesses
completamente diferente do dele
eles se despediram ele voltou e cada um
voltou para sua realidade
se a tua felicidade estiver vinculada só
o ponto final da história
você tem maior potencial de se frustrar
por isso eu aprendi que confiar tem a
ver com ser automotivado os grandes
líderes que eu conheci eles importavam
um pouco com a grama do vizinho ou com a
time line do instagram do amigo que por
sinal vai ser sempre mais animada e mais
divertida que a nossa
esses empreendedores eles olhavam muito
o espelho da sua própria história
algum amigo meu especial fazer até um
pouco melhor
o sonho dele é ser capa de uma revista
de negócios famosa que ele fez ele
comprou uma das edições da revista
recordou a capa e colou no espelho
todo dia ao acordar ele vai no espelho e
ele se vê na capa da revista essa é a
auto motivação diária dele é de vocês
qualquer motivação diária de vocês
confiar pra mim virou mais do que uma
palavra confiar pra mim tem a ver com o
modo de pensar
tem a ver com ver o mundo como ele
poderia ser e não só como ele é confiar
pra mim também é ressignificar os seus
contextos confiar pra mim também o modo
de agir é construir suas próprias
oportunidades confiar pra mim tem a ver
com você aproveitar a jornada não só
linha final
confiar pra mim é um modo de ser e será
automotivado e ser um realista otimista
confiar fez um jovem do interior de
minas buscar encontrar oportunidades que
para muitos seria muito distante da
realidade dele
foi assim quando eu virei
líder de equipe aos 18 anos de idade foi
assim quando eu tive a possibilidade de
trabalhar na maior consultoria de gestão
do país
foi assim quando decidiu abrir mão dessa
consultoria de uma carreira promissora
nessa postura ia para facilitar a
formação de jovens líderes através de
uma onde foi assim quando ganhou o
primeiro concurso de startups
foi assim quando eu estudei na melhor
escola de empreendedorismo do mundo
e foi assim até aqui hoje com vocês
e como eu e como eu fiz o confiar virar
um hábito pra mim me conectando com
gente boa
botamos sorriso na cara e entendendo que
as dificuldades que vou enfrentar não
são maiores da minha vontade de fazer a
diferença no mundo
agora imagine o estoque de yu
imagine a julia imagino césar e se eles
não tivessem confiado e vocês quantas
vezes confiaram pra valer na vida de
vocês quantas vezes como é que foi esse
processo mais importante dessa resposta
é a próxima
se eu pudesse confiar hoje por isso eu
quero fazer com vocês a gente começar
hoje a onda do confia e pra gente
começar pra valer
eu quero que seus olhos o colega do lado
de vocês olha bem nos olhos dele e diz
assim confia agora olha para seu colega
da frente ou para trás e diz pra ele
assim confia e se a gente pra gente
moldar o mundo dever de verdade a gente
só precisasse disso
por isso para a gente encerrar e eu
quero que vocês levem isso como lema da
vida de vocês e me para o máximo de
pessoas possível
eu quero que no 3 a gente deu o nosso
lema do futuro juntos o 23 confiar
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]